the mood meter is fantastic it gives the
child the opportunity to show their
feelings preschool rule was developed at
the Yale Center for emotional
intelligence be partnered with child
care learning centers in Stamford
Connecticut to develop a way to teach
emotional intelligence to our youngest
learners right from the beginning of the
day the teacher has a good idea of where
each child is coming into their
classroom they decide how they're
feeling which quadrant of the mood meter
whether they're angry happy sad or calm
and they put their picture down there so
they're recognizing their emotions
they're able to label it when children
come into schools or during the day and
they are either anxious or angry it will
affect the way that they are learning in
the classroom because they are not
paying attention and they're not
listening
and it makes it learning very difficult
for them the ruler program provides a
fundamental tool set for the children to
be ready to learn it allows them to
recognize to understand to label to then
express and ultimately to regulate their
emotions and their feelings and why do
you feel sad
the teachers then recognize that the
children are coming into their classroom
with a myriad of different feelings
every day and it's hoping the children
realize that I'm not always going to
come to school happy they learn a new
vocabulary like anxiety curious it's not
only using happy I'm hearing a lot of
more communication you're not just
taking the toy but can i play to a lot
less of the aggressiveness a lot less
hitting a lot less pushing we've noticed
they're they're really much more verbal
about their emotions in the way that
we're thinking creasing their empathy
which is a high level skill for a three
and four year old so it's not just
helping one particular child who is
having the behavior is helping the other
children and it's helped them to sit and
focus and to learn the other parts of
the curriculum and when they give man
ideas feelings they are ready for
learning integrating ruler was easy as a
teacher they're just doing it and it's
fun to do it's hard enough to start
communications with your children and
have them being comfortable with talking
to you about their feelings as you're
introducing your child to something that
they're natural with his colors rule
eight I think knowledge is helping
children's life he has been our feeling
to regulate our emotions I've started to
use the mood meter myself at home with
her because you know that's our way of
communicating it's really a tool that
they could
forever and it sets them up for success
and in an increasingly competitive world
these children need all of the
advantages that they can possibly
something we can't always choose the
feelings that we have but we can choose
how we respond to our feelings and we
can teach children how to do the same
you